нарешті не чую звуків снарядів я
можу спокійно вийти надвір не боячись
що почнеться обстріл я по тобі чогось
себе в анапу завтрашньому дні
ще ми не буду люблю на роботу єхидно
житель
я олексєєва дарина мені 18 років я з
горлівки зараз я навчаюсь у харківському
національному педагогічному університеті
імені григорію сковороди
я козакова немає money we 17 роки я
замість оббивки за раз направити своїх
артисткам національного модельного
університеті я вивішу
шиповим їм при носінні виглядом core з 5 3
їм жити я і зрозуміла що мрії здійснюються
головне нічого не бояться і вірити в себе
і любить і в свою Україну називають не
щодо
нас платила мрія та віра у світле
майбутнє про їжу тут до нас
[оплески]
[музика]